rick stroud back here on the rich eisen
show who covers this
uh this great team one of my the team
that i'm winning for
i believe he's winning the super bowl
the tambay times how are you sir
hey rich i'm doing well so
what'd you make of last night rick what
came out of last night's game
do you think when when when
uh that was really about it i mean um
you know
we always say you know your teams look
ahead and
and of course they you know you can only
play the game in front of you but even
bruce arians was nervous about
that game with the giants that the day
the night before the game
uh to his team you know he did the old
you know right the word assume up there
right and circled it in certain ways and
told people
it's what he did guys don't assume yeah
yeah he wrote it on a chalkboard you
know
[Music]
and you know he he let them know that
you know you can't just
can't go out there and think that that
the giants because of their record are
gonna
you know just gonna lay down and you
know you're the bucks and and uh
and that's all it's gonna take so he was
he was pretty plugged into the fact that
uh
that they may have have to struggle in
that one and it was a struggle it's
weird rich you know like
just the very atmosphere of metlife and
i've seen this a couple times with this
team
saw in chicago a little bit in the
beginning of the game against the
raiders
you know when they go to these stadiums
and there's nobody and i mean nobody in
there
except you know players and coaches um
you do have to gin up some some energy
and they weren't able to do that early
on that's not an excuse but
the game's played by human beings and um
you know i think they were just happy to
get out of there
you know with a win and i thought i
thought the giants played really really
well and i thought
you know they had a good plan for the
bucks and um
you know they got the win and that's
really all they went there for
interesting so you're
you're saying again because there was a
struggle as we all know in week one
where there's no fans in the superdome
that they're that they are in spots
where there are no fans because
tampa has been letting fans in if i'm
not mistaken
since week four against the chargers
that they have begun begin playing in
front of a a small
audience that that that that void
affects them is what you're saying it's
i think it does
yeah and i i can't explain it i mean it
probably affects a lot of teams
it's just different and and when you see
you know i mean
it's monday night football right and so
you know players are conditioned i mean
this is the
only game on tv they want to play well
they know everybody's watching and so
you kind of get the anxiety
and you come pulling up to metlife and
and you walk in
and it's it's it's not like you see on
tv where they pipe in the crowd and
it's just different you know and
football is one of those games where
i don't know you can you can feel the
energy and
they they didn't feel it and um you know
they were on their heels quite a bit
early on and so i just think they got to
do a better job of
being able to start fast and there's
some things that happen brady comes out
at 4
4 and then two bad snaps by ryan jensen
below his feet
you know all of a sudden the timing of
the throw is off and you know
and you have to kick a field goal so
those things happen but
but you know credit the giants for
playing really well and um you know the
bucks were fortunate they
picked up a flag and they got out of
there with a with a win
rick stroud of the tampa bay times here
on the rich eisen show let's talk
antonio brown
was this a was this a given i mean was
this a foregone conclusion that brady
was going to get him
and that um you know uh he has been
a guiding hand in all this despite what
bruce arians and jason light
has uh said on the subject matter yeah i
think i think
you know tom has been behind us from the
beginning now you know
if they weren't foreign to you know or
you know
weren't in a situation that they were in
i don't know that they'd do it
um just to do it i i think that you know
when they went to chicago
and they had so many guys hurt at that
position they weren't practicing
mike evans was was playing he probably
shouldn't have
um you know scotty miller was hurt that
day i don't think he got a target
and then all the other receivers of
course you know chris godwin and
other guys have been out i think it i
think it drove home the point that you
know look
you know we can have tom brady in this
good defense and everything else but if
these guys can't get on the field with
them
uh it's gonna be really hard to win so
you know they were looking for depth at
the position
they just haven't been able to keep
everybody you know together
healthy and and then you know there was
there was antonio's suspension coming up
so the more they thought about it
you know um they got guys on the staff
firing left witch
larry foote and you know antoine randall
that were teammates of this guy
and you know look if tom's going to let
him live at his house i mean you know at
least you know he's got a ride to work
every day
um you know after a while it starts to
sound like you know
as good as it gets where he's jack
nicholson saying you make me want to be
a better man you know it's kind of
uh you gotta make brady helen hunt but
it's just uh
it's kind of kind of worked out that way
but i think tom
you know tom's gonna get guys that he
wants to play with that he's comfortable
and um look
if he can play i mean you know when he's
motivated he's
one of the best receivers of all time
well i mean i don't think there's any if
i i think you know we're going to see
the antonio brown that we know i mean
even in the cup of coffee that he had
last year with the patriots before
another allegation
uh was made known and then blew that
whole situation up when he started
uh denigrating robert kraft on social
media
we saw that he was the same old antonio
brown and brady must know that too
the question is is uh has there been
some sort of social media ban put in
place
by the bucks i mean i know that thomas
is i'm serious man i know that tom is
is his landlord and friend and
compatriot and i guess
watcher uh but what about what about the
phone
i mean i'm serious rick has that been
put in place yes you can tell
it wouldn't it would not surprise me if
they told him he needs to stay off of
that you know and other things
i mean they you know bruce told him he
goes look it's you know it's going to be
work home in this case brady's home but
work home and then back to work again
like you just
you know with the covet protocol it
takes you you know a week week and a
half to get these guys through it and
and you just you can't you can't go
anywhere they certainly don't want to
you know on on on social media i mean
you know that
that blew up in his face everywhere he's
been um
and and so you know i i'm i'm sure in
talking to
the guys over there they think that even
antonio realizes that
you know this bruce said it would
believe the second chances like its
fourth or fifth chance
and you know he blew up the three teams
that that had either draft picks or
money invested in them and they don't
have the money invested in them
it's pay to play you know the way it's
structured so if he wants to play
here's his opportunity with a really
good team that could go to a super bowl
and he can play with tom and you know
tom trump's not putting his legacy out
there but
you know a little bit of his reputation
maybe you know to to stand up for this
guy
so we'll see we'll talk to antonio this
week and and kind of get a better feel
but um you know he's still got some
issues ahead of him off the field and
you know on the field though they they
really they could use them
when does that happen wednesday when you
get to chance to speak
on wednesday yeah tomorrow yeah i mean
he's able to you know there's nothing
going on today because i think they're
all off the road
and whatnot of course the bucks are off
but yeah we'll see him at practice
hey look you know uh to meet rick stroud
of the tampa bay times here on the rich
island show
i said it um when when brown got signed
that it seems to me that brady has moved
into his new house
if you will and i mean his actual you
know jeter mance
i'm talking about his new football house
and he has rearranged the furniture to
his liking
i mean he he has he has set everything
up he's got you know the
the the film room here and he's got the
you know the uh furniture the way that
he likes it and uh
he feels comfortable in his house right
now that he's set things up
the way he likes it and is comfortable
in it would you agree that
he has reached a comfort level in
entering this week nine contest against
the saints that he
clearly did not have in week one going
into that game
oh yeah i mean you know look they they
if you look at the first couple weeks as
as you know what would have been a
pre-season
right um you know his first three games
he goes three touchdowns three
interceptions but what happens after
that
well all of a sudden you know now he's
17 touchdowns one pick so
he's definitely more comfortable um i
can only imagine what it's like for the
patriots and it's like the country song
that's my
my girl my whole world but that ain't my
truck when the guy drives by his house
right
he's watching he's watching um and
him win all these games in a different
uniform but you know he is he's he's
very much
at home i think and yet you know he he's
also
driving home to point to his pla to his
teammates that
um even when you don't play well like
they did you know last night
um or play as well as they as they they
need to
you got to find ways to win these games
and rich i've seen them lose a hundred
of these games
um probably probably two or three
hundred of these games
uh where you don't play very well and um
you know
that doesn't happen you don't walk out
of there with a victory and believe me i
mean when they won the super bowl
they've only been six and two three
times in this franchise's history if you
believe that the last time was o2 when
they won the super bowl
and i guarantee you you know those those
games there were some pretty ugly games
on the way to uh beating the raiders in
san diego and super bowl 37 and no one
talks about them but
you just got to find a way to win them
so a couple quick hitters for you going
out the door rick so
what's godwin's status is he coming back
sunday
do you think well i think they'll
probably give him another week i mean
it's possible they said from the
beginning they could be back he still
got that those fingers taped together
um it's going to be a pain type
threshold thing but
um with with antonio coming i don't
necessarily think they'll rush him back
they just got to get him healthy for
more than a few weeks sorry missed four
games
and so i guess this is a first class
problem and you said that brown was
partially born out of the fact that
their injury
level uh at the position was very high
uh how does it work when everyone is
back healthy
how how will this actually work
well i i expect them you know losing o.j
howard changed towards the dynamic they
were a two tight end team for a big part
of the
of the year and they'll still play three
tight ends when they want to when they
want to pound it
they've been using joe hague in some
situations but i think you're going to
see a lot more four wide receiver sets
they did some of that
a couple of weeks ago and it looked
pretty good
against the raiders and you know you get
as many guys on the field as you can
they can't double everybody so
i think that's probably the way they'll
go i mean i think you're still going to
see scottie miller i mean he'd be the
guy probably
you know that antonio most resembles
um but they'll make use of all of them
for sure and then
last one for you rick um the biggest
conversation i think
on twitter last night during the game
and
afterwards uh was the way aryans looked
on the sideline
um with the the uh the face shield
that when it rested on his face with his
glasses made it look like he was wearing
two pairs of glasses
and then the headset uh with i guess the
communication box right across his
chest um in a manner that i don't ever
see think i've ever seen uh from any
coaches did anyone
bring this up to aaron's post game at
all
nah brilliant into you know he's he's
too
he's too uh cool to not be able to pull
that off you know even with that big
uh electronic box on his chest i don't
know what
what that's supposed to be looked like a
video game or something but
um you know i i'm glad he just survived
it you know he's 68 years old man
standing on that sideline as cold as it
was i know
um you know i was worried about him
right uh he looked like he looked like
he puts
put through some stuff but yeah i don't
i'll have to talk to bruce here in a
little bit on this conference call and
see if they can't uh
give him a better look than that rick
i'd like to know it's not look hey
whatever works but this is a choice and
i don't know if it's like you know if he
wears that
around his waist that it it hurts his
back in a way that they came up with a
way where it's just right there it's
it's his i'm sure it's one of those
communication boxes you press a button
and you're talking to the rest of the
coaching staff
literally was resting on his chest and
uh i've never seen that
i've never seen that he had also you
know uh obviously his
his trademark lid um it's just this is a
choice and i'd love
to know about it that's all i'm saying
i'll certainly ask him i
i think he's happy with the visor though
i think he i think he likes that better
than the man
okay very good rick thanks for the call
appreciate i know you just got off a
plane
uh let's chat down the line uh you you
are covering
you are covering a major player in the
2020 nfl season
no doubt about it that is a fact but you
knew that yeah well
it's been a lot of it's been different
and um yeah i appreciate you having me
on race thanks so much got
nfl stroud on both twitter and instagram
tampa bay times
rick stroud right here on the rich eisen
show hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that
watch more right here